it's not much bigger than a walk-in
wardrobe but this store is enough to
support papua nerala and his entire
family nirala sells water purification
products here every month he earns
around 400 euros from his shop nirella's
business is cash only so he doesn't keep
receipts
i don't pay taxes i can't save anything
my expenses are too high there's rent
school fees and lots more
at the end of the day i just don't have
enough leftover to pay my taxes
many indians don't pay their taxes
in delhi over 100 mps are under
investigation for tax evasion or
unreported earnings and it's estimated
that indians have spirited around 400
billion euros in undeclared earnings out
of the country
before being elected india's prime
minister narendra modi promised to put
an end to corruption but the parties are
still buying votes
though it's unclear where they're
getting the money to do so
so there's a system which operates the
black economy and in this system the
policy makers have to be a part of it
the the executive consisting of the
bureaucracy the police and the judiciary
they have to be a part of it and the
businessmen have to be a part of it so
there's a triad that runs the black
economy so you have to break this chart
if you do not break the triad the black
economy will not come under control
real estate agent akash agarwal says
india's booming construction industry
provides the perfect cover for hiding
money
when a property is sold he says a part
of the total sale price is often hidden
from the tax collector
whenever the buyer will
come
in the market to buy a property so
basically there are two components one
is white and one is black so whatever
the the total consideration price is
there
out of the total consideration cries you
need to pay some portion
of the premium
in cash and some of the portion invite
to conclude a deal
plus many indians don't have a bank
account that blurs the boundary between
legal and illegal transactions some
estimates say as much as 480 billion
euros in tax revenue has escaped india's
government they're funds that could be
used to improve the country's
infrastructure and its government
services